so what you're about to see is a
conversation that I had with Jason
Brubaker
Jason Brubaker is a graphic novelist
he's an artist who worked for several
years in Hollywood for DreamWorks he
worked on projects like blade he also
worked on Kung Fu Panda and he finally
decided to leave LA and leave Hollywood
which didn't fit with his own values and
decided to go on his own and create his
own projects since then he's put out two
series of graphic novels one is called
remind and the other is Citra I've read
both series and really enjoyed them my
kids also enjoyed them as well it is
very beautiful art and and very dramatic
storytelling very much worth your effort
if you're into that kind of thing
so we talked about his creative process
how he inserts symbolism into his work
we also talked about graphic novels in
general my own project God's dog which
is in the process so there's a lot of
great stuff and I was really excited to
talk about him because I really enjoy
his work and so I think you'll feel that
excitement and you'll enjoy this
conversation as well
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so what you do it be doing any editing
after you know once we get the video I
might I might edit in some pictures of
your work okay okay but I usually don't
edit a lot of the actual content yeah
okay unless you say something really I'm
always so hesitant to say weird date
okay you're not you're not at all of
what I've watched quite a few of your
videos and you're not at all
you're not the edgy you don't seem like
the edgy type who's looking to create
controvert it just keeps me up at night
too long you know I don't I don't want
to go there yeah I understand for my
books I think I'm kind of the same - I
don't I don't like I mean I will if I
need to go somewhere I will but I don't
like to provoke I don't call people out
I don't do all that stuff that a lot of
people do on the YouTube world you know
so so we're kind of we're kind of so I
think that's probably why one of the
reasons why I like your channel too is I
it was straightforward talking about
comics with the world of comic books and
and how to do it how dumb how to make it
work and there's a generosity about your
approach and even in your books yeah
there's such a generosity in terms of
having a lot of your stuff even free
online for people to access um I think
there's an that approach is I think it's
exciting it's an exciting approach to
see that happen to see it be possible
and you I seemed seems like you're
you're still making a living with this I
don't know if I'm wrong yeah it's it's
been it's still going you know I mean
I've been doing it for four years
full-time now and it pays all the bills
and so I figure hey you know I might as
well keep doing what I'm doing there's
something working that I'm doing you
know and and yeah that excitement about
putting stuff online was because I saw
other people doing it back in the day
like in 2009 I saw people doing that and
there wasn't really any money in it but
it was just so exciting to see that wow
people are sharing this information and
they're getting their stuff out there
and they're passionate about it and it's
better than this other stuff that's
professional you know so it was just it
kind of just changed my whole
perspective on it because I was really
pursuing agents and publishers at the
time
and Wow just jumped right into the
conversation sorry yeah no that's I'm
Margaret I'm recording so this is gonna
be it's gonna be it
III think it's I it's exciting when I
see one of the things that the online
space seems to have provided to is a way
for people to be directly in contact
with with your with your base you know
if when you're going through a publisher
and you're publishing books and they're
going out and you know it's if it's
deadline and all of this you know you
have to actually physically go to comic
shops or whatever to get any form of a
return from your readers but I guess I'm
the online space it must be way more
satisfying to this immediate connection
yeah yeah you get you I like to say that
I have online editors you know I'll post
my stuff online and then I'll get a
bunch of people responding to it and
then I know what to edit and they'll
even call out like spelling errors and
grammar I think you should say it this
way and then I'll use that for the
editing purposes before I actually
publish the book so it's really helpful
to really test the product as well just
by putting it online and yeah it's great
and it is kind of a double-edged sword
because I do like to step back away from
this kind of being this public face that
is always communicating because that's
really tiring and it's yeah it really
fractures my time and then I can't get
into that deep focus that I need to to
make the thing really good and it takes
you know a year of deep focus to be able
to do that kind of thing
so jumping on and off of line is really
just really fractured my brain and I
have to pull away from it and unplug
from everything and like I don't like to
do social media much anymore because you
know it's just it's just too much and it
does it doesn't give me any it doesn't
give me very much you know I feel like
social media is more like something I
can just share with my friends but not
people that I don't know even though I
know it's marketed to everybody that
social media is the way to share with
the world and you get famous that way
yeah but for me it's just like no it it
drives me nuts and then I don't gain and
done and then I'm focusing on the wrong
things and then you know yeah I know I
think I know I know exactly what you
mean what I've been trying to do is I
start really early so I tried to start
work at 6:00 in the morning so I get up
I try to get up it's like 5:30 whatever
I started you know do my prayers and and
kind of beginning the day stuff and then
at 6:00 I try to work and just carve so
from 6:00 to 10:00 that's it like it's
just carving and listening to podcasts
while I'm carving you know not not
engaging with anybody and then I come
back and I eat breakfast and I do my my
eat I start the more email stuff in the
online stuff so by the time I'm online I
feel like okay I've actually
accomplished something I don't feel like
I've lost wasted my whole day you know
on some idea which can totally happen
even before breakfast you oh yeah yeah
yeah uh Network it's well it just
depends on people like for me it's the
best time you know I'm just I haven't
eaten I just have a cup of coffee and
I'm just I'm there in the carvanha and
then that's it you know cool that
reminds me when I was working at
DreamWorks because I worked at
DreamWorks for about seven years and
that's when I was working on my first
graphic novel and I finished it and I
just couldn't put in the time to to make
the next one which was the conclusion
yeah and so I found myself getting up at
5:00 and working for about two hours
before I went into work and yeah I was
going I would be like yeah this is super
satisfied and like it doesn't matter if
I don't get anything done here at work
you know like I've done my thing you
know and and I was able to get that
second graphic novel done by really
early yeah and and it was a stressful
time in the family like just had kids
wife was having postpartum depression so
there's a lot of things going going on
but yet I still was able to block out
that time and you know help with the
family when everyone woke up I was I was
serving breakfast and taking kids to
school and I had already gotten in my
two hours you know yeah to me that has
been the the only solution really you
know and so what I what I try to do is I
start so I start really early I get my
first four hours of carving done then
after that if I don't get back to
carving I don't feel totally guilty if
I'm doing online stuff answering email
doing these kind of conversations and
then at 5:00 that's it
I'm done like I'm finished and then I'm
with the family I'm helping with dinner
with the kids and so it's like you can
getting up early is like the solution to
so many problems you know yeah if you
can do it took oh I'm not an I'm done
I'm such a night person you know in
college I was the guy who would go
around the clock like I would stay up so
late at some points that it was like oh
there's no point in going to bed again
as well stay off until late afternoon
the next day because it's like 5:00 in
the morning I've just been staying up
just kept staying up later and later
later until he kind of like goes back
yeah until I had kids that was a night
person and then now it's like I've been
forced to be a morning person and a
Kairi allele I kit I mean I love being
up before the Sun comes up but sometimes
you know I just can't do it but yeah but
I what I do is I have a really late
lunch so I have a lunch at like 2 or 3
o'clock
I'll try to work from the time I get
into the office all the way till lunch
and then after that it's just you know
it's especially when you're doing the
kind of work you're doing you know you
just need that ultra focus or else I'm
just gonna get sucked in so I want to
talk about I want to talk about your
work I I've read two of your series I
read they're remind series and also
sifri first of all Mike my kids my kids
just swallowed it up like they just
loved it so much cool my son was 14 he
read it twice and my daughter you know
she's not as good in English but you
read the whole thing on her own once and
now she's she started reading it again
and so there's something about and I
think I was trying to figure out what it
is about the books that is so compelling
um and I think I mean I'm gonna speak
I'm speaking also because I'm not
objective in this you know I have my own
my own perception but I do think that
there is in both books there is a deep
symbolic intuition so the way the world
is structured you know even before the
actual story it's like the way that you
structured the world is so intuitively
right even though it's even though it's
fantastical that I think that it just
connects right away with people you know
this in in your reminds story you have
this underwater world where these kind
of like lizard type creatures then you
have an above water world that isn't
aware of what's going on
underneath and then connection with that
underwater world leads to a disjunction
between mind and body it kind of
confusion where like mind and body don't
fit and then they try to fit him back
and it doesn't work and so there's like
crazy adventure about you know you know
the whole like you know different
persons and different bodies which is
exactly the experience of death you know
it's exactly that experience of being
underwater whether it's dreaming or
dying all of that is all about
disconnecting mind and body and so it
just it just because you wouldn't think
about it but it just makes sense that
that's what happened if you go
underwater and so it all it's crazy and
it's wild and it and it just keeps
getting crazy and crazier as it goes but
it's still the basic logical symbolic
structure makes sense so you you you
gobble it up no matter what you know
yeah that's that's awesome to hear you
describe my stories because I've heard
you describe so many other stories
that's great I love it that's cool this
is something that I'm curious about is
that in terms of your process do you so
like let's say I describe I described it
that way
for you is it just an intuition in terms
of this story just makes sense or do you
feel like you actually worked at making
it I don't know how to say it like did
your you use your kind of rational mind
to make it make sense or was it just
like no this is just an intuitive
process where like a songwriter I've
heard songs where it's obvious that the
songwriter didn't totally understand
what they were doing but they tapped in
to some reality and they were just
they're just laying it out even though
they don't it's not rational yeah I I
don't think I ever went into it like
knowing what I was doing and I mean part
part of the part of the reasons I I like
to kind of stretch into like these
different worlds as because I've
realized that in retrospect it is
because it kind of like nullify it it
like stops people from having
presuppositions when they start reading
your your thing and you know if I start
talking about a story that has to do
with my
past religious experiences suddenly
people have these you know they they
might put up roadblocks because they're
you know and yet I can I can talk about
that all through these these metaphors
and allegories and all that stuff and
and you know also I've read the Bible my
whole life and so it's it's just kind of
like I think it's ingrained in how I
think about stories and the structure of
the world and how life is and so to me
that's I think just kind of a natural
way that I look at storytelling is
what's the the hidden meaning of all
this you know and then also I look at it
like parables like I feel like our
stories that we write are are like
parables and they're not meant to be
understood the same to people who have
the knowledge to understand them versus
the people who don't you know like like
this like if someone really wants to dig
into the parables they can find a lot of
different hidden meanings verses you
know and even Jesus himself said you
know like if you have eyes to see and
ears to hear then you can understand
what this means if not then you know
maybe I'm understanding that wrong but
so so he was saying him to everybody but
there was a certain group of people that
could understand the deeper meaning and
so that's kind of the way I look at my
storytelling too he like like yeah most
people will probably interpret this
wrong but you know but I I would like to
think that there's a certain group of
people that will really get it yeah and
and they'll be really obvious yeah you
know well in terms of like if you in
terms of symbolic structure at some
point it's not it's not even about
interpreting and right or wrong um
because the structure is there and the
structure is making the story happen and
so there is like especially in cetera in
your second series that I that I read
there was more of that let's say kind of
parable sense where you could feel that
certain characters
pointing to certain things kind of like
you CNCs Lewis where you have Iceland
it's like a salon is Jesus it's not as
explicit of that in that story but you
have certain things which seem to be
pointing to some Christian aspects let's
say but the best type of symbolism I
think the place where it works the best
in your stories is where it's the actual
structure of the story it's like the
structure of the stories laying out
reality in a way that helps you to you
know that is so is fantastical but it
also feels so right
you know like in Citra you know why why
does it feel right that there is a
there's this desert with all these like
kind of parasite creatures that are
there and that will come out and kind of
attach themselves to you it's like why
does that feel right and if that doesn't
it's not that's not a reality but when
you need it and how and you see how it's
related to - to sin to a certain extent
and it's related to passions and being
kind of sucked into something some some
kind of desire that you have and it all
makes sense am i and my 14 year old son
he was reading he was reading the books
and he said he said oh yeah I really
loved how he made the these these I
forget what they're called he's like
parasitic creatures how he made him like
demons like he made them like your
passions and there's like a visible
version and an invisible one and they
kind of mirror each other and so it's
like all of that makes make sense even
though when you think about it in terms
of reasonable world it doesn't it
doesn't connect anything in the in the
it does but it not directly it is really
structural yeah and I don't think I like
to just let do like CS Lewis does where
it's like it's a metaphor like this
character equals Jesus or whatever i I
you know acknowledge that exist but but
yeah I like to kind of like trick people
like if there is a character that's a
deceiver I don't want to make it obvious
you know because he'll deceive the
audience you know and yeah so so yeah I
don't I don't really know if there's an
you know I wasn't trained in it
necessarily I just absorbed
you know as a kid and storytelling and I
just knew what I loved and didn't love
and and so when it came time to write
and finish my first story which was
reminded that the first graphic novel
that's like the first thing ever like
really finished that was a big story and
so I kind of just put it out there going
man I hope I finished this right you
know I hope people like it because I
don't know how to tell stories but but
you know the thing I've learned through
working in Hollywood is like it's it's
more about as an artist just like your
your interpretation of how you see
things and and and you know telling a
story in a unique way is kind of the is
kind of like what I'm trying to do like
like Miyazaki's stuff is a great example
of it here like it's a different culture
different worlds different fantastical
things but it's just a window into this
other world there's a lot of times not
even a real good middle beginning and
end to his stuff it's just kind of like
opening the curtains here you go there's
this weird land you know and what and I
hear he doesn't even know how they're
gonna end when he starts on a no-risk
he's just waiting for him to and that's
how I work you know a lot of times I
have these loose structures in place but
but I can't adjust I mean honestly I
just pray about it a lot that that God
will help me day like right you know
figure out what this is supposed to mean
you know and and so a lot of times like
with sits right a lot of it really
evolved as it went it started out just
as a story of the little girl and the
kid was that kind of the side character
yeah boy but but as it ended the boy
kind of got more dominant in that story
so yeah and the character of the little
girl is great it's such a wonderful
character yeah I think that's one of the
reasons why kids like it so much because
the characters so has that kind of its
kind of forthright and and and and
buoyant you know which is really is the
best like the best of what a little girl
can be so you really get that in her
yeah and I think that's probably one of
the reasons why the kids like it so much
is that character but the other thing
that I really really
was impressed by the way you were
putting things together in the book is
how you use you really you really take
your time to tell the story especially
in the first books of sitri you kind of
just take your time and you're using
page turning as it as a dramatic
dramatic tool and I'm wondering if I
have seen that as much in other comics
I'm not I haven't followed comics in a
very long time but there are some times
when you get to a point and you know
that on the next page it's going to kind
of reveal some secret and then sometimes
you turn the page and there's almost
nothing on the other page it's like this
moment of wait so you it's a you know
it's just like it's just a breeze of
wind that goes by and you're you're
expecting to find the solution to the
problem that's being set up but it's
like no this little pause and it's like
oh you know and it's just like pulling
apart and you turn the other page and
then you finally get the bill back you
know and I I really appreciate that I
was really surprised at how effective
that that can be I never I never thought
about it so much like well I remember
being a kid and reading some comics
where you you yours having something
being set up and you're I can't stop
from going to the last you know you know
I can't stop from jumping ahead until
you're you're ruining the surprise for
yourself as you're as you're reading it
because you can't stop from but if you
have to turn the page then there's this
whole dramatic sequence is being set up
yeah and I think I started thinking that
way because I would put it out as a
webcomic so it would be one page a week
and I was really I mean a spread one
spread away or remind and I was really
trying to just make sure that people
came back so I was really trying to set
up those pages to where you know you
would you just want to turn that page
and you want to wait for the next week
right and another thing I was thinking
about was you know when you pause a film
you you you pause that that mood and the
color palette and all that stuff and I
was always turned off by the comics that
every panel would be a different mood
and tone color palette and scene
location yeah and it's just like flying
all over and every panel is competing
for your attention and I really wanted
to be like when you
when you have the book open on a spread
it spits it's almost like you've hit
that pause button and you can absorb
that mood one scene at a time and then
you turn the page in it it can go into a
new scene in the new mood you know so
those are some of the things ours I was
actively thinking about in when I was
designing it but yeah they I had a lot
of people talk about the page turning
really how I do it well and and I didn't
realize I was doing it that well I guess
until so many people so well for kids it
was great because it was also because
the first time I read it my
nine-year-old daughter she doesn't read
in English she just she reads only in
French and so I read it to them so we
sat there with the book open and we
would read and I would read and I would
point to the to the bubbles like where I
am in reading it and then at some point
we'd have to stop right cuz it was too
late or we had to just you know and it
was always this was so frustrating for
them because obviously it was so easy to
stop at the end of a page and they're
like no no no yeah we're shutting it
down now and we'll start tomorrow so it
was a lot of fun it was actually quite
pleasant to read that to my kids and
also it's it's it's great to read us I
mean it's also great to read a story
that you can read to your kids and you
don't have to worry what's going to be
there it's almost seems impossible that
that happens now you know you your kids
are watching something on Netflix and
it's supposed to be for kids and then
you get a glimpse of it in like what
yeah what are they what is this you know
are the same you get a book from the
library and you're like what is this
monstrosity like how how is it that
they're marketing this to you know ten
year olds yeah yeah and the themes do
get pretty heavy and dark but you know
I'm curious how parents are going to
take that but so far no one's said
anything really bad about it I mean
that's the nature of reality though like
yeah evil is evil yeah you know you know
I'm really against the whole concept of
of kids stories being like I want to go
to this grocery store and get a pop some
bubble gum that's my goal yeah I did it
you know it's like no listen we got a we
got a show they show the evil and
you can resist it or whatever it is it's
always I'll see about subversion is the
problem in a lot of kids stories today
it's that it's not it's not that they
show evil and good or that they show
something playing out is that they
really try to show something upside down
like they just they they just really
want because it's also because of the
desire to to surprise and the desire to
shock and you know well if I'm gonna
write a book and I want to get attention
then I might as well write a book where
vampires are the good guys you know and
human beings are the bad guys because
how am I gonna get attention if I don't
do something that is shocking and
surprising yeah so so it's almost like a
it's a it's a strange revolutionary
process because you know just because we
need to get attention we tend to want to
to do these upside down things yeah yeah
we're gonna get we're in a good space
now because everything is so upside down
that all we need to do is tell real real
stories and then like we're the ones are
gonna get attention exactly yeah yeah
suddenly why are you you you're really
thinking outside of the box normal world
in a normal story like a normal
hierarchy and a normal relationships
between people and it's like wow you're
you're just so creative I can't really
yeah you how do you think of this but
you still you know but now it's the
trick is to mask that the to mask that
is not going to be go down that path go
down the wrong path
I don't know how is it you know you
almost have to set it up so that people
think that it's going to continue
inverting it I really it doesn't well
that's you know I think you know that I
that I'm working on a graphic novel with
an artist court and that's exactly the
strategy that we had my brother or not
when we wrote this was let's create a
story that at first glance when you look
at it in terms the terms of the story
you think oh this is gonna be
everything's gonna be upside down and
then just turn everything back in the
story and just put everything back in
place so it's like let's have it let's
have the main character be like a dog
headed monster you know who's the saint
so it's like this dog headed Saint oh
that's gonna be subversive but then it
just everything kind of turns back
I think it's possible to do it I think
it's I think it's impossible to do it
yeah yeah that's kind of what I I'm
thinking I actually want to talk to you
about my next story some sometime later
and it kind of has that same thing I
know when I launched it it's going to be
something that people are going to
immediately go oh you're talking about
this yeah I'm on board but then when
they get to the end of the story they'll
be like oh you weren't you weren't
raising the same flag as us yeah exactly
it wasn't the same but I'm curious
though like who what is your what have
you seen to be the people that are
following you like who what type of
people are buying your books do you do
you have a sense of it um it's a lot
older people than I thought it would be
I you know I've always kind of thought
well as comics so it's gonna be kids but
there's a lot of my age group is like 30
to 40 year old men you know there's a
there's a lot of women in there too but
I realize it's it's just kind of me it's
like I'm my demographic is me you know
not my it's mainly the age you know and
so I'm I'm trying for my next books to
try to hit a younger audience by by by
making it a little bit easier for them
to embrace not not necessarily by making
it more kitty you know can be tsipras
already a pretty young story yeah that
everyone can embrace but like for
instance my next my next book is that
I'm gonna be working on is this thing
called faux boast it's a spoof on the
classic [ __ ] and so I'm trying to make
it more teen friendly like having a cute
girl on the cover mm-hmm instead of
instead of a little girl you know
obviously 40 year old guys are gonna
have little girls and so they're gonna
be like oh it's a little girl you know
whereas a teenage boy is gonna be like
yeah but I'll try not I still you know
my goal is not to make it like
sexualized and all that stuff you know
there's plenty of comics that do that
for us so yes yeah you just be dropped
one more drop in yeah and oh yeah let's
do the same thing everyone else is doing
mystery
and so what about the like so you're
using your using patreon you're using
crowdfunding mostly do you use IndieGoGo
which which platform are you is mostly
using I've used Kickstarter mostly okay
IndieGoGo this last time for
crowdfunding and it worked really well I
still am not sure which one to do going
forward
so I like both Kickstarter and IndieGoGo
as far as patreon I do I do like it I
just I don't I'm not convinced it's the
business model I want to have hmm
mainly because you know my product is
not necessarily me and my behind the
scenes and all that stuff and yeah and
my how-to content my product is my books
and so I want I want the books to to be
the business model and to sell and to
make enough money to support the
business I feel like you know if Apple
were to say hey you support us on
patreon so we can keep making computers
then there's something wrong with their
computers you know yeah that's just how
I think if I wasn't if I was telling
myself as an artist who was given
classes and teaching and stuff like that
then then I think patron would be
perfect you know yeah but the strategy
I've been using with it
that's been working is almost treating
it like a Kickstarter campaign so every
so many months all I'll have a pledge
drive where people who are $5 and up
will get a free copy of my next little
floppy book you know and it's only for
patrons and but it's a physical reward
and so that drains a lot of the money
from patreon as well right in mobile it
makes it almost like your pre-selling
yeah and then eventually I will launch a
Kickstarter for for that next book and
it will be like a hardcover graphic
novel you know that the public to
consume and so this is I guess about in
terms of just ideas so when you move
from your your let's say crowdfunding to
the market how because now you're on
your own this is the the big the biggest
thing I've always wondered about so
publishing is you know you have your
real fan base and you're doing your
crowdfunding you get the book done
through crowdfunding then you put it out
on the market
so then how do you get like you how do
you get do that other step like are you
doing distribution yourself are you
doing all that on your own the first
book I was and I was shipping out books
everyday and Goods and sending boxes to
Amazon and boxes you know libraries and
and it worked it was successful but it
was just it became a full-time thing
after work and so so eventually I
realized like this is I'm gonna go crazy
doing this and I don't have time to
actually do the next book so a friend of
mine had a distributor he was using
which was an independent distributor
called SCB distributors and they just do
like art books and little little comics
and graphic novels and I I pitched in my
book and and because it want the first
one one the Z rat grant which was a an
old award back in the day before
Kickstarter was big it won this grant
and so they said well we we like books
that go through this grant and and since
you're selling so many of them we'll
pick you up you know so I signed a
contract with this distributor and
they've been handling Amazon and all the
bookstores and Dimond so they'll do the
comic shops as well and and it's a
full-service distributor so that's
really helped and they also have like
the the doors into the bigger
distributors so they can get into all
the bigger bookstores at least people
can order the books through the
bookstores but it doesn't mean they're
on the front shelves you know and so
that's taken a big load off of my back
and then I've kind of pulled the plug on
my online stores because that's just too
much work to keep getting orders and
fulfilling ya know I and you know I know
some people are like what what are you
what are you complainin about this is
great you know it's great to get orders
but it's it's just that fracturing that
time yeah that makes it so difficult for
me you know and I end of the day and at
the end of the year I really wanted to
get that next thing done because that's
the biggest thing that sells my last
book is the book and so
so yeah I've found the best strategy for
me as is unload all the distribution on
my distributor if as much as I can
don't sell anything online until I have
a Kickstarter or an IndieGoGo campaign
and then I can fulfill it all at once
like one time a year and and maybe
during a Black Friday type sale I can do
it a sale but then beyond that it's just
lock myself in my room you know work on
the books yeah do the things that I need
to do to get the actual project done so
I'm curious about because you said that
you your stories you you don't
necessarily know the ending when you
start is that is that with your mention
I I think I I do have a general idea of
the ending I just don't know how I'm
going to do it you know I don't know
that the how those pages are gonna look
or how the maybe how that last character
will look like the like the the the
character in cetera the end the reveal
that was that came to me right when I
was drawing those pages I didn't know I
didn't even know I don't want to give it
away for people there's a lot of things
I didn't know until I got to those pages
okay for Citra and so but I did have
that like a like a bullet point list
kind of written out like okay now
there's the confrontation with this
character and blah blah blah
yeah but I didn't realize it would
unfold the way it did and that it would
be that I would design it that way and
so there's a lot of unanswered questions
and I think I like that because it keeps
me excited about it in the process you
know when I discovered I'm like oh yes I
want to draw that now you know like
let's get this part going and I'm
obsessed over it but if I thought about
it two years ago then and now it's time
to execute those final pages that I've
already figured out all the details of
then it's suddenly just a job it's kind
of like just kind of yeah and so do you
think do you when you're thinking about
your stories or when you think about
your
or I'm thinking about your process do
you think imagistic aliy or is it you
think of story like in a linear man you
see images first yeah it's you it
usually starts out with if I can just if
there's a mood that I'm feeling for a
certain subject and it kind of there's
an image associated with it then I
really want to try to figure out how to
preserve that that image with that mood
that I that feeling that I felt when I
wasn't thinking about it and
transcribing that into a story somehow
is is kind of the most critical thing
for my storytelling and if I can string
together enough of these and convey
those moods and those feelings and
emotions and then I feel like I'm it's
working you know my newest story the one
I was gonna start next year I don't have
any images for it I've actually started
writing a script and so it's a very
backwards compared to where I've usually
worked but I think I need to for that
story because it's very complex in all
the pieces need to fall into place so it
doesn't mean I'd have to work that way
it's just I think I choose the method
I'm gonna work based on the enjoyment in
the process yeah you know like yeah like
I can't understand because Citra likes
it sir really feels like this bubbly
like the whole thing is bubbling in
terms of moods and colors and and you
can just feel the joy of exploring you
know even just these these moments where
you just see the sand you know in the
desert kind of coming up and and there's
this whole so there really is this
exploration of mood and through color
and everything and I think that that
like it like you said it does a sword
wouldn't have to be that way you could
tell a different type of story but in
that context especially with the
character that little girl it almost
feels like that like you're you're a 10
year old girl again you know you're here
again
I'm just never a 10 year old girl 10
year old again and and it's like you're
just you're discovering you're on this
adventure with her and the actual
drawings make you feel like you're
on this adventure with her yeah not just
it's not it's not doesn't feel as much
from the outside where you're just kind
of looking in this story that's
happening the set up of mood and these
these color panels that are just kind of
streaks of color kind of bring you in as
if you're you're you're experiencing it
yeah yeah and that's kind of what I
wanted
I have trouble doing like the history
stories where let's just imitate what's
been done and and try to get it right
because it's because I really like to
have these worlds that are not really
our world it's kind of like a parallel
world because that way you you you don't
know what to expect from page to page
and so you're always wondering okay is
there gonna be a spaceship in the next
scene I don't know is that part of this
world or not no and so so I really I
just love those kind of stories and I
think that's how all of my stories are I
like I have you know another three
stories that I've have in line to do
next and they're all the same you know
none of them are just like okay let's do
a history period piece now you know I
like I do like reading period pieces but
as far as investing the time and
creating it it's like it sucks a little
bit of the creativity out of it if I'm
just imitating what's been what what
history was like yeah yeah and so tell
me a little bit about cuz I don't know
anything about your own because I know
you're you're a Christian it seems like
you're a Christian what is your like
what is your journey like what where are
you in that sense I kind of Protestant
are you Catholic I have no idea I have
no idea um well we go to a Nazarene
Church so I consider myself a
nondenominational right yeah my parents
were missionaries in Africa and
Switzerland so when I was like 2 to 5 we
were there so I knew French but I don't
know it anymore yeah I know of what -
[Laughter]
that's the only word I remember no I
know a couple but I'm anyway so yeah
they were missionaries and then when we
came back when I was five and
I just love drawing ever since I was a
kid so that was my goal was just to draw
started my career when I was twenty I
went to Hollywood worked in storyboards
and and concept designs and then
transitioned in animation about a
20-year career and I just never really
felt fulfilled with it
it wasn't until I kind of went back to
my parents house and saw all these old
drawings that I made which were all
stories surprisingly all my little stick
figures were stories and nothing was a
drawing just for the sake of drawing
right and so I realized that I want to
tell stories with drawing that's what
inspired me to draw was to to the
drawing should accompany a story and so
I started to kind of at the age of 30
trying to just do my own stories again
and that's when I started kind of
enjoying art again you know and so I
just started making animation and
started working on graphic novels on the
side of work and then then I eventually
moved back here because I just felt like
LA was I was beautifying the wrong
message and it just became really clear
to me and you know I it came down to
this point where I woke up and I don't
know if it was just a dream or whatever
but I woke up and eyes and I heard over
a repeating in my head come out of her
my people you know that line from
revelation before before the and you
know at one point I was just like you
know I've always felt like my art and my
storytelling is it's it's a gift from
God to do something with it you know and
I I didn't ever know what it was but I
always knew there would be something
that I could do with it you know and but
I just never felt like I was doing that
I was I was being trained in art in my
career but I was always just yeah
beautifying the the wrong message yeah
beautiful that I don't believe in at all
so so it really bothered me and just got
to where it's like I don't want to do
art anymore if that's what it's gonna be
about you know I don't feel like that's
what I should do with my gifts and so um
so that kind of drove me to move out of
LA I moved back home to Idaho convinced
my wife of it we made a one-year plan
and everything worked out and she loves
it here now okay great and it's relaxing
and I'm actually getting stuff done and
you know I've been able to pay the bills
because it's a lot cheaper here than it
is and yeah so so I mean I kind of have
the same that I have the same faith all
my life you know I can't really name a
point when I feel like I became a
Christian because I've just always grown
up in that environment hmm I've always
believed and and it's just more of a
wrestling with with how I believe and
and and if I'm living my life in a way
that's that's you know I'll hear well
done good and faithful servant you know
so I guess and and that's kind of the
reason I do what I'm doing it's like I
just want to make stories that that mean
something to to me and to God and you
know that will make him happy you know
I'm saying and that that when I'm gone
like it can it can keep can keep
reflecting some sort of light into the
world you know yeah so anyway so I'm
curious about what your like what your
inspirations are or at least like what
because one of the things that I mean
I'm putting what you're saying through
the lens of my own experience which is
that as when I grew up I grew up in the
Protestant church is more it's not de
non dumb it was a Baptist Church kind of
conservative Baptist and I always felt
especially as when I got a little older
when I was young I didn't feel it as
much as maybe very it was underneath the
surface but in my 20s I started to
really feel like there was a tension
between me making visual art and wanting
to to use visual symbolism and use
visual representations and this kind of
Baptist tradition that I was Marta
until it was like this tension that I
struggled to to get to get through
because there weren't that many
inspirations from let's say the
Christian tradition that I could pull
from and I was like so where am i
pulling my my influences from and I was
and it was this like it was a it was a
difficult time for me at least to try to
figure all that out so I don't know if
that's something that you've experienced
or that you kind of had to think about
or deal with yeah I ever you know when I
moved to LA and when I was pursuing like
getting the career started my parents
were really encouraging and so that kind
of gave me the the feeling that okay
there you know God's got my back if my
parents have my back then then you know
then this there's some good in this but
I never did see the connection between
God and art and it was always just make
money and make a living and make a
living and do you know do the things
that sell and stuff and there was there
was moments in the career when I'd be
like I can't I'm sorry I'm not gonna
draw that you know I just thought that's
just not me and so you know I wouldn't
get a job or I'd get fired from the job
there's one job where this guy was like
make it as satanic as you can like it
needs to be satanic and I was trying and
trying and finally fired me he's like
I'm sorry you just can't do it I'm like
I don't know how to draw stuff that
looks really satanic so anyway yeah I'm
drawn chains and stuff but it still has
like a cartoony look but yeah I remember
having conversations with other artisans
that's just saying well you know they're
artists just aren't they don't have they
don't have like I don't know if I what I
said exactly like they don't have faith
like they're not thinking about things
and they're like in this arts like well
yeah they're there they're the more
faithful ones I'm like wow you know so
it's kind of a strange like what kind of
faith are they are the artists thinking
about are they kind of making up a faith
you know is it just about feeling
spiritual you know so so anyway I was
always kind of confused just like where
did my art fit into this and I think it
was when I was in my 30s that's when I
really started realizing like like there
you know you can beautify you know we
can beautify things with art and we can
beautify the wrong things and I don't
want to be a contributor to that anymore
and so I really felt like God put me
there to train me
and give me that ability to tell stories
to learn from all these directors to
learn deadlines and then he said okay
now it's time to leave and now it's time
to to do something else you know now
that you've been trained and you can
beautify anything that's been given to
you
start start beautifying this yeah you
know yeah makes sense it so what are
your what do you feel like are your
influences that you identified some of
the things that you that really kind of
when you were younger it kind of got you
excited well I loved the newspaper
comics like okay our field the far side
in Calvin and Hobbes so that was kind of
what I wanted to do that first
Calvin Hobbs I can kind of see that a
little bit yeah yeah especially with
sister because I used inks like he did
so that was a big influence and then and
then I started getting into Japanese
animation kind of in my teen years and
that's when I moved to LA so things like
Akira
you know the animation and and all the
Miyazaki stuff all the like spirited
away like really influenced me when I
was in Hollywood and the story telling
that I wanted to do I just wanted to do
a a Christian or a Western version of a
Miyazaki film you know because his it's
very much rooted in hit what he believes
and and yet is so anyone can it anyone
can absorb it yeah which is so neat
about it no I think your I think that
your approach is great and I think that
looking at Miyazaki as a way to because
one of the problems and I'm sure you've
had the same experiences I have is that
a lot of the problems with Christian
art and Christian storytelling is that
it's so shallow it's just yeah it's so
message driven and it's and it's so
shallow that it doesn't resonate with
anybody or it resonates with people who
are so like that's all they'll read and
so they won't read anything really good
they won't have the problem of having a
career yeah yeah I have a real big
problem with a lot of Christian art and
Christian music and stuff it's like to
me that the the ones that really rise up
are the ones who are not following the
mainstream paths that are done and
they're just they're brilliant artists
like as far as musicians goes there's
this guy named josh garrels who is just
an independent musician and his he he
does music but and it's not really
labeled Christian but it's definitely
Christian and it's some of the most
amazing music I've heard you know and
it's so anyway there's that kind of
thing yeah yeah you know it's like I
know people's hearts are in the right
place but it's kind of like that it's
like that zeal without knowledge like
you got to have the knowledge of the art
and of the craft and storytelling to
really be able to tell the stories you
want to tell in a meaningful way that
will impact people yeah you know and the
strange thing is we have the best
stories like you know Bible stories are
there they're amazing you know in terms
of of how profound the story of Christ
is is you can never reach the end of it
you know you always every time I read
the gospel I'm always surprised I even
sometimes I'm like wait this detail
let's say it's like how is it that I've
read the note the read the story of my
whole life and then this one tale I've
never noticed and so so yeah we have
that we have the best story it's the the
thing is that we have to be able to see
the Bible stories are stories again
without feeling threatened by that
you know without us thinking that the
fact that these are stories is somehow
threatening to our faith you know and
that's what a lot of the kind of
American evangelical Christianity has
struggled with which is like either it's
a literal telling of something in a I
don't even know how I can I'm really
struggling even now to think that way
anymore but it's like this is just a
description of something that happened
and it doesn't actually have a story
structure like you
mmm it does have a story structure and
so does your life yeah
like it so does everything you go
through also has a story structure you
know your day has a story structure if
it doesn't have a story structure then
then it's a miracle that it was written
the way it was written because it's so
so much more dense than any stories that
can be written today and it's also who
would care like no one is interested in
in you know me I don't know like
describing me tying my shoe for five
pages it's like no one is interested in
that unless I can make it into a story
which is not impossible but uh yeah yeah
so yeah yeah I kind of worried that
after so many stories that I've written
people be like hmm this is kind of the
same stories remind this kind of things
story is Citra know this kind of story
is that yeah you know what IIIi don't
want to be condescending to your readers
but it's all the same story so don't
worry about it yeah that's what it comes
down to really yeah I mean you can see
how all the stories have a have a basic
pattern you're not gonna be worried so
much about telling the same story you're
just gonna be worried about telling the
same story in a way that will be able to
get get people's attention and get them
excited about it but it's not gonna be a
different story it's just going to have
a different different clothing you could
say something like that
yeah yeah so I'm curious about your
graphic novel winner when are you gonna
have that thing out well we're in the
same situation you were when you were
working a dream work which is that cord
he just had a baby a few months ago and
he's doing this in his spare time he's a
graphic designer so he tries to get up
early and get at least an hour out you
know an hour in the morning to be able
to illustrate it we finished we it's
gonna be about five four or five books
I think we're hoping for books there
might be more and we've we've done the
thumbnailing of the first the first book
is complete um nailed and now he's
drawing it out and so I think he's inked
about 1516 pages and the book is
I think it's out it's like 120 so it's
gonna do me so it's still gonna be a
while before he gets and he's really
putting the effort in for those who have
seen some of the art he's not he's
really wanting to make it beautiful and
take his time and I'm fine with that
like I'd rather it be a quality product
and and we put it out and so what we're
hoping is that is that we can put out
the first book and then there'll be
enough excitement that we can crowdfund
the second book and then he can quit his
job and just do this full-time like if
we could do that that would be amazing
cuz then we could just speed it up and
and start putting the books out you know
once a year or something or ya can could
you crowd fund once you get enough pages
done could you crud crowd from that
first book and then get enough money to
I think I I was hoping to but I mean
cord is he has a family he's got you
know it's like I think he doesn't want
to risk everything right now and I can
understand that I if I was in a
situation I might think the same like he
doesn't want to risk everything so we're
probably going to to wait until it's
almost done before we start the
crowdfunding for the even got it okay
but it looks I mean I know if you've
seen some of the images that I really
excited I think it looks great
yeah I've I was actually you know he was
he submitted it to my to my art review
board forum reddit thing when I was
doing that and and the pages looked
really good and I was like interesting
and then I saw a lecture you did and you
showed the same page it's really strong
stuff it's not it doesn't look amateur
at all it looks really strong really
well done and it's something that I
would definitely want to consume so and
then and this story I mean that we
worked my brother and I worked on that
story for years like four years we wrote
it as a screenplay and we we hired even
like a like a reviewer to kind of go
over each draft to to get it really set
up and so I feel like the story's really
is is tight like I'm not worried about
the story and so I'm excited to see how
it's gonna do because in a way when we
wrote it you know in 2010 it's almost
like ten years ago
we finished it in 2009 I think even it
was almost as if
world wasn't ready for this story the
thought the references were so weird you
know it was like this st. Christopher
character with a dog head and and these
sound like a pillar saints and and all
these these like warrior Saints and
Giants and Dragons and it was just so
strange but now it's like I've been
talking about this stuff for like four
years now
yeah and so by the time it's out I think
there'll be enough people who will kind
of at least understand the references
that for them to get excited about it oh
yeah
oh that's cool I didn't realize it was
about the Saint Christopher and the dog
head I remember you talking about that
in one of your videos and I looked into
that because I was like that would make
an interesting comic well I bet it's
funny because that that I had the same
experience I found out about st.
Christopher offer like a 2002 I think or
2001 and and there was a book called I
figure what he was called the myth of
the dog man written by some scholar and
a really subversive book but a lot of
good information in it and I was reading
and I was like man why isn't this not as
wise no one made a character out of this
story and so I even the first time I
thought about the story I actually
thought about it as a as a joke as a as
a comic book at first I thought about as
a comic but as a joke so I was like oh
so we could have st. Christopher and st.
George like the two monster killers the
monster and the monster killer fighting
together and it was kind of like making
fun of almost like these movies that
make fun of Christianity I kind of
thought about it that way and then after
a while like no I could flip this like I
could I could turn it back so that it
becomes becomes actually something that
is that is showing that is showing truth
but it has a has an the imagery seemed
subversive at first glance and so just
slowly working on the story forever but
it's a it has an epic background like it
the idea was to try to I don't know if
you read it was Neil Gaiman's season of
mists it was part of my my influence for
writing this he wrote this graphic novel
a Sandman graphic novel that had he used
Milton's Paradise as the basic structure
for his world building and so he created
this world where there's like the the
Satan is in hell and you have this
hierarchy of angels and then in this
hierarchy of angels you also have all
the pagan gods and everything obvi he's
a you know whatever he's Neil Gaiman and
then and then and so it's like he tells
this story that's inside the story of
Paradise Lost and he has Cain and Abel
as characters and then he has the devil
the devil decides that he's quitting his
job and he's giving he's like he's
giving hell over to whoever wants the
keys to it and he leaves so that's the
basic of the base of the story I thought
man he gaming is so subversive but he
can write he's using a Christian
structure which is Paradise Lost which
is based on Dante's structure and he's
able to tell a story inside that
structure and I thought he imagined if
we could do that but it wouldn't be too
like it wouldn't be too up he've
everything but it would actually be to
kind of show the the power of of this
structure and I'm like okay yes all
right Gaiman I'm taking you on I'm gonna
try to you here I'm probably not easily
he's an amazing storyteller but at least
that was my impetus yeah try to outdo
Neil Gaiman I saw the the Amazon version
of his Good Omens where it's kind of a
saint similar thing where he acts you
know the biblical structure but he
really just tweaks it does every yeah no
I agree I agreed that I I watched I had
read Good Omens because he wrote of
Terry Pratchett and then I I watched a
series too and I had the same feeling
again I'm like man it's like there's so
much of it that's interesting and
there's so much of it that is just
obviously just being subversive to be
subversive and so it's like why can't
why don't we have storytellers like that
yeah exactly I mean oh my goodness it
would be so amazing the kind of stuff
that could come out because it's not
like you have to destroy it to make it
good you know there's there's so much
there like if he would have done his
research a little bit more into the
roots of all this stuff it could have
been even better yeah but he he I mean I
he's he is who he is
he represents it's like yeah he's not
he's not yeah you know we had a bunch of
it would be better to me but it'd be
better to his audience it's like this is
the thing that happened and this is the
thing that happened and I think that
that we need to be the answer to is that
in in the 60s 70s and 80s let's say even
maybe in the 90s the people who
understood symbolism were the the
revolutionary types like they were the
ones who understood symbolism and the
Christians and the more traditionally
minded people they didn't understand
symbolism and so they didn't have any of
the tools you know and so in the comics
world like if you have you have the
British Invasion yeah Alan Moore in
Gaiman and what's his name the other one
anyways you had these guys coming in and
they had such a grasp of symbolic
structure but there were all Kaos
magicians they were all you were all
like you know there are witches and they
were you know they're all that's what
they were and and they were they were
putting it out there but their their
grasp of structure was so powerful that
there are stories ended up being
convincing and so it's like yeah man we
need to flip that back just take it back
because this the imagery is ours anyways
like the imagery is it's it's this you
know Alan Moore wrote Constantine and
it's he's using that a Christian
structure he's just so twisted you know
you have a boy you have all these
stories that use that are in a Christian
mythological structure but Christians
have have been so wary of seeing their
worldview as a mythic structure that
they don't they don't dare go there like
they don't dare do it it's like no let's
jump in let's do it like this is the
best mythological structure you know and
so let's just use it and anyways we'll
see what happens so so it kind of
reminds me it makes me think that my
story Phobos that I'm working on this
next year it's kind of a reverse of that
it's like I'm trying to take all the
classic horror characters which and I've
always looked at as an escape from God
like these stories are all presented so
that you can so that people can not have
to think about if God was present in
universe right at least that's one of
the reasons you know Harry Potter
where's God in that I know when no one
knows but all these stories are kind of
an escape mechanism yeah and so but I
was always fascinated him with him with
him growing up so so I made this story
back when I was a teenager but I infused
God into it like Frankenstein actually
meets God he's having nightmares when he
sleeps and he's experiencing the after
lives of all the characters that he's
made up of and so he eventually meets
God and Peter and and he gets his own
soul you know and that's what I wrote
when I was a teenager but I realized
when I was rewriting and now that I want
to take all these these these classic
horror characters and stories and say
okay what if God was in the picture here
you know how would that how would that
story go you know and the the general
theme is every knee shall bow you know
meaning that doesn't really matter what
you are you know you you can't escape
because you're not in the category but
anyway it's that's the it's a great yeah
in terms of monsters monster stories
monster stories have an underlying you
know horror movies a lot of horror
movies actually have an underlying
traditional structure like they have an
underlying most horror movies are
actually very conservative if you know
if you if you look past the the gore and
the killing you know in and they they
kind of deconstruct that in the recent
horror movies where they show that a lot
of the stories always have a a kind of
break of morality like you they break
someone breaks a taboo and then the the
killings actually end up being a a
retribution for that break of the taboo
which gets resolved in the end by like a
virgin or whatever some kind of
character that's innocent and so they're
in the horse structure there's something
that is that is actually close to a kind
of fall Redemption story it's just that
it's it's out of whack and obviously
it's it's appealing to all our lower all
our all our lower passions and
everything and so I think there
definitely could be a way to
you know to knowing it instead of
deconstructing it just flipping it back
you know not like the screen movies we
just want to show how smart they are and
how they can they can figure it out but
I actually just dive into that structure
and make it as potent as possible into a
Redemption or a like into a redemption
story yeah I'm telling the one story
that has to be written that no one has
written yet and I'm giving this to
anybody who wants to do it because I
don't have time to do it is a story
about a zombie that wakes up that story
has to happen no one seems to be able to
write that story but that wakes up and
it is not a zombie anymore that he's
that he's that he's a zombie but that
all of a sudden he comes self conscious
and then what does that mean like what
would happen if a zombie became self
conscious because that that would be the
redemption story right there yeah I
think it would be the redemption story
it would be like it would be like a flip
you know until there's a little bit of
that in what's that what's this I forget
the name of the story some people gonna
kill me for not remembering this story
the one they made a movie with Will
Smith about what's the name of that
story oh I am Legend yeah I'm legend in
the original novels a little bit of that
where novels good where they everything
kind of you could miss the movie they
missed the whole point of the novel I
think it's supposed to be a flip where
you know they become society and you
become the monster it's like that
anyways but but there was a little bit
of that where there's like an awakening
of this of these zombie creatures that
awake and become a naturally
self-organized Society but I think a
zombie story it was a zombie that wakes
up I think that would be great hmm
anyways that's my idea maybe I can work
that into Phobos I don't have any
zombies in there and it's only because I
do but it's saved for later as
afterthought because I there's so many
zombie things I just I'm like yeah but
that's the one story the one zombie
story that no one's told and you know if
you do it yeah I have this story that I
think no one's told off to tell you
about it later all right yeah
all right there is something that I I
just I don't know how to present it to
the public yet so maybe that will all
save for a private conversation all
right all right all right well now
everybody knows that we're we're gonna
be having private conversations about
the future of Christian storytelling all
right we've been going for a while Jason
I think I think we should probably call
it quits for for this conversation but I
it's been a lot of fun and I and I'm
hoping we can we can do it again yeah
definitely I really appreciate you
having me on your show all right I'm
really happy I really like your work and
and I'll point everybody to it I'll put
links to your your webpage and to your
different projects and so everybody yeah
Jason thanks for coming on and I will
talk to everybody else very soon if you
enjoy the symbolic world content there's
a lot of things you can do to help us
out if you're not subscribed please do
go ahead and share this to all your
friends if you can get involved in the
discussion we have a Facebook group in
which people can talk about these
subjects I will put all those links in
the description and also if you can
please support us financially by going
to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com